[Music]
Wow this is crisper are we gonna succeed
there's always a chance that you can
blow it
[Music]
let's see what happens so Roland
everyone says CRISPR is really easy to
do and I was interviewing a very
prominent researcher the other day who
said to me any idiot can do CRISPR is
that true
I'm not true about any idiot but it is
easy and we gonna find out so what we
want to do is we want to knock out a
gene in a human cell line yeah I chose a
gene that putative Lee is involved with
the immune response to dengue virus and
the reason I chose it is because there's
a theory that if you've had dengue virus
and you have an antibody to it and then
get infected with Zika it helps the Zika
virus copy itself which might be
responsible for the damage that we're
seeing in babies so you and I are gonna
solve that problem right hopefully I
mean what are the basic steps that we
need to do to get started first we'll
have to define the genomic region that
we want to cut then we take that
information and put it into a design
software in a CRISPR design software and
the third step is ordering the oligo
nucleotides for um the cloning of the
guide armies then you have to order a
plasmid what's the name of our plasma
it's 90 CRISPR v2 and we're gonna put in
here our twenty nucleotide sequence
that's gonna guide us to the portion of
the gene that we're gonna not exact so
we've got the ala goes and we've got the
plasmids ready to go now we're gonna
pipette the now we gonna pipette
everything we're gonna put it all
together right okay let's do it
so first of all we take a tube this tube
is sterile now see like you already have
the problem with ona water tube is right
so this is like actually a micro
centrifuge tube right it's a 1.5
milliliter micro centrifuge tube this is
where we will we will set up our
reaction so the components we will need
is the plasmid right the enzyme rather
the enzyme only works in a specific
environment so we'll also need the
buffer the correct buffer and we also
make it like a feasible volume so we'll
add water to it go down push the bottom
down
ah just one time so um so here's the
deal hold on John pick up I can I take
the pipette you were way too fast so you
had bubbles in there so let's try it it
already ruin the experiment basically by
not knowing how to pipe it you already
like on a bad path right you don't not
fail you necessarily it's very robust
okay but it's up optimal all right all
right here we go again
okay all right
very nice easy-peasy I didn't know it it
was so much fun to do it decrease in now
lick off yes that was that was proper
penalty oops
yeah I think now you kind of like see
fate like you feel a little bit probably
because you put it like see like how
much liquid there's still left yeah I
should be fine you know let's let's keep
going and now you wore ticks again
oh come on nerve-wracking yeah I don't
wanna make this day woo poor tech think
you're totally worth taking away with it
and then you spin it real quickly
that's it that's it goes I'm 37
let's go around I don't think you need
to videotape that one but the beginning
I said is it really easy you know can
any idiot do this yes but then like I
got a sense of like there's some pride
that no you've got to really be kind of
skilled to do it I think that is a
certain skill level where it's very
necessary right like if you take a
random person from the street and say
knock out CD 30 32 nth b-cells mean like
this mammalian cells there is no way
this person would do it right not in a
hundred years it's really easy for
people who already know how to do what
to do molecular biology you just
discussed pretty much everyone knows
about DNA go to RNA and most people are
like I'm not so sure right
mention all egos plasmids cloning and so
on you will lose everybody
[Music]